vous savez autour de la table je vous ai
fait subir beaucoup beaucoup de choses
regardez tout ce que j'ai fait subir à
ces personnes qui sont là qui
travaillent tous les jours pouvait
commencer à sortir parce que vous allez
pouvoir vous venger regardez ça venait
avec moi crise il a regardé on se
retrouve dehors pour la vengeance est
parti alors on y va
c'est là
[Musique]
somavia
oui mais paraît il faut que je veux
mettre mes mains d'une certaine façon
merci grand mère se venger je vous le
dis alors je sais pas du tout est-ce
qu'on peut m'expliquer comment je dois
mettre vas-y aminé madani et mines et
ben tu as tu peux me dire quand à bercy
et 1000mercis commenté hier à au bouddha
au bout d'un proche venez flâner et
comme dans les poches de regarder ja
billets d'euro millions
c'est peut-être le gagnant suis là dans
mon coeur c'est christophe carrière qui
me l'a offert pour mon anniversaire
merci donc est-ce qu'il faut que je
fasse mon téléphone il est parti
d'accord ça va vu l'équipe j'y crois pas
trop attention
ils doivent se mettre tout mais ils sont
très proches la wii
non mais on va viser c'est parce que
j'ai déjà les pieds mouillés
non c'est bon merci merci c'est bon
alors là donc je me mets comme ça je me
fais comme ça on essaie voit sa marge à
bord mais c'est tout et c'est jean
lemire aux données et aux détenus
allez-y baleti
[Applaudissements]
on voit tout s'entend soyez discipliné
tout fait soyez dissiper
hahaha
attention attention et à ses rivaux
non
des comics et des grenades
patients les patients robichaud le maire
jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
c'est vous vous avancez non voilée venue
après c'est fini la loi bertrand pas
mercredi pas partie de la table dans
l'au delà
[Applaudissements]
non non non mais t'es là là là là c'est
général tel arrêté là soyez pas lourd ce
n'est pas loin non mais
[Applaudissements]
jean claude malo jeux de ballons
mercredi l'oms a bien trop sadoulaeva je
vais manger du sud un travail que j'aime
beaucoup
attention c'est parti mon bertrand mon
chéri à regarder je mettrai boulot super
crew séjour à perdre ont baissé mais
c'est quand même bien le long du corps
huawei bravo jean luc envoie mes samia
[Applaudissements]
à gagner
merci en tout cas d'avoir et avec cloud
sur les 8
[Musique]